[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we bump
whatever
Kingsley here today hey welcome to the
show
thanks thanks I'm excited yes have you
ever seen oh yes I have Tim sent me some
episodes Oh tie well yeah when he asked
me to contact you guys so give us some
nuts we were together I love it it's
over antic I was very confused about how
Allah was set up at first because I
couldn't tell if y'all were webcamming
or the same room but I think the
Energy's really good since fun
conversations really like I guess what's
the word but I enjoy that yeah some
people don't like that like natural it's
fun so people like hey you get back to
the topic now no I like rants and the
only people that I would know that we
ever do that why you so offended you
talk about someone else oh I seem like
you were tiff is not offended
would you say that you're a good person
I hope so
I've been having some things lately I
don't know what are you thinking what do
you mean you don't know my life out is
that why you you took out your old
videos and then they're on private I
took them down because I was having a
crisis there was a lot of reasons I
checked them down I was tired of people
comparing me to that because you changed
I've changed a lot - what - are you able
to talk about it or you want to keep it
under wraps no I mean remember your
older content and then I recently
visited I was like oh shoot like we're
gonna have him on as a guest and then I
was like oh what like you only had like
three videos yes I put those three up
because I felt like those accurately
represent me as of now we would you do I
miss this they're just privates head
it's my 10th year on YouTube so like
we're gonna be better oh gee thank you
and I'm gonna do like a lot of like
throwback Thursday type things where I
look at those videos and kind of
commentate on them so I'm kind of just
making it like fancier than it is and
creating it like a channel so I'm like
seeing it as like the videos are gonna
be in the syndication does that make
sense yes yeah sending in your own
videos yes don't so don't be back this
year it's not plus in ten years - like I
know a lot of our fans - like this is
like our twelfth year but they haven't
watched our old content they didn't even
know it existed so then your new fan
base is probably gonna see and be like
what I know this yeah and algorithms a
mess like my stuff would pop up before
my new stuff it was just like I actually
read them that the algorithm is working
great from where did you read that I
read it on one of the two filters from
you to statement they're celebrating
yeah YouTube says it is actually good
doing great you know what I made two
bumpity-bump
you don't know Steve you like the boss
should allow the straight-faced oh no
I'm just saying that keep the biggest
role this is gonna be a very long day
just says false because that's what
YouTube says YouTube says it's actually
right you know what I found out though
so it does suck for the users like it
sucks for us but there it's winning for
them because what ended up happening is
you know the recommended feed so they're
getting way more people clicking and
watching for a longer period so the
users sticking around on YouTube for a
longer time but it sucks for the
creator's
yeah come on we're over drivers exactly
it was a teenager it was crazy I wasn't
really thinking about what I was saying
it was profane um and just like wow that
was just a wild little girl famous all
of that nothing's wrong with that like
I'm still it's just nothing's wrong with
it yeah I just you know I feel like when
you're online people all see things and
they expect you to be that way because
it's almost like a video diary and I
feel like people feel closer to you yeah
um and it's just harder to grow and
evolve when it's just sitting there for
consumption all right so then they call
Trajan hole you in that character and
then they want you to be that and if
you're not then it's like oh man you
don't meet expectations yeah it's like
taste son Tay Zonday it's like why
aren't you doing Chocolate Rain the
third sequel
you know exactly for thousands of times
it's very frustrating yeah it's hard but
laughing at telethon what would you like
to taste uh no because I don't you know
my jewelry stand right I didn't know his
singing voice was his speaking voice oh
yeah when I heard him speak oh just like
a Decepticon oh it's amazing he's like
Oh Steve it's nice to see you hello
Barry yeah he sounds like a hawk like a
50 year old white like talk show guy
like he's still at it
yeah no no no different flavors on his
released his thousands chocolate rain
video vanilla rain he does my voice over
he's just a podcast
yeah yeah right his voice is so hot
smash it because we're just talking
about how Donald Lana Del Ray puts me to
sleep
yeah I put on like well if I'm driving
it's like actually lethal it's actually
scary situation if law and always think
cuz I'm like look guys I'm driving but
if I pull up on Sunday podcast it's like
oh [ __ ] okay but his voice is so
thunderous you know go to sleep Steve
yes like Judith but there's like Zeus is
talking at you from [ __ ] the Mount
Olympus and [ __ ]
when did you come up with this like
feeling of I need to do this change like
like I need to be responsible for my
youthfulness and I'm a different person
I represent myself differently because I
really put everything out there so I've
said some stupid ass [ __ ] but for me
it's more like well look at how much
I've grown since then not much and I'm
like there's like hundreds of thousand
people have watched a share ready we
can't don't watch a [ __ ] it exactly so
it's like it's not hidden it's still out
there even like not on like three
uploads or whatever right yeah just sent
me in my rebeccablack video on Instagram
it's like cackling I just want it to be
teachable but I want to be in control of
teaching but it's cuz you're gonna
release it but now you're commentating
on your thoughts of what you release
yeah so yeah just last year I feel like
um was rough I've talked to other people
and they had just rough years I don't
know what was going on like mercury what
all that stuff so great yeah
did that happen like seven times my wife
knows all about it sometime you know
about this [ __ ] until Nikki started
talking about it she's like into gems
and stones and all this stuff uh and
your smile with your sign and what year
what our what whatever and then she'll
tell you your Gemini with rising or
lowering or whatever yeah yeah that's
the only reason why I know about Mercury
retrograde other than that we don't know
what are you I'm a Capricorn
I felt Aries rising oh yeah oh then you
you're one of those two okay yeah people
a lot going on yeah that's right what
does Aries rising mean um Aries is
supposed to be it's the first sign of
the zodiac so it's like the most pure
impulsive innocent not really thought
out which is like the exact opposite of
a Capricorn that [ __ ] that errors would
be like [ __ ] I like I hate people
legit the birth of the zodiac oh and
then Capricorn is like the end like the
most evolved and like have like seen
everything December or January or
December 20th premiere cuz I'm uh I'm a
Aries month but I think I'm a Leo rising
I don't know what a sleeping is though
what is it this come down leapin yeah
mercury mercury sleeping there are so
many houses every planet has a house
somewhere like love summer careers the
Sun sighs there's so much snow showers
right now no house heart he has no clue
why was you last week but now I'm
converted so I think you're weird so
yeah I'm just like why are you out of
the culture like oh I'm in here in the
culture and you're like out in the rain
I've been to parties and I've seen like
watch parties and I've seen what's
happening and it's just not for me like
I would like it if it was a movie but I
can't see myself tuning in let's start
in the beginning but I heard the
beginning is all fall it is um you you
know what you should do start season
four that's where it's really good maybe
do the recaps until I try to watch what
I fell asleep
listen give it six seasons
and then it gets really good the sixth
season but that's what people always say
to me in [ __ ] what do you watch oh my
gosh I watch a lot of reality like I
watched across drag race the challenge
that was good
I can't watch too much of the the
RuPaul's Drag Race cuz then uh I want to
start doing my makeup that we don't even
realize that I want to start do it yeah
and then I'm like ooh I need some more
blue and I'm like oh what the [ __ ] out
what am i doing like I got is called a
cut crease that's what you're doing it
is a cut crease
hey you learn that from your wife what's
a cut crease um so it's when you wear
eye shadow right and then you'll use
like foundation or like white or
whatever and then like it's like a
really sharp crease like on your eyelid
oh then you can put another color so it
just looks like two hard colors Niki's
explain to me probably seven times I
still understand but I know it when I
see it but I don't know what it I still
don't know what it is yeah after
explanation it's tough and I watch like
makeup artists and stuff I don't know
what they're doing do you do my cast no
always just soothing you just like it I
just like personalities like we've
talked about Brett maroc like I like
Brett moon rock I don't know what he's
doing you know I just watched Gigi I
don't know what they're doing but it's
like they're funny to me I'll watch them
put on me that's true Brett minutes
laughs so when I asked you if you're a
good person the main reason why I asked
you that is because when you came in we
were talking about American Idol
auditions and how you miss when people
who suck we're on yeah we were talking
about that too but that's something that
a lot of people are like well that's bad
you doesn't matter like that's bad
because you should have make fun of
people but I'm like that's a point they
they even had that show cuz it's
entertaining but the auditions were
hilarious yeah yeah like it was iconic
we were like the pants on the ground
like the old man anyone remember that
wait walk around with your pants on the
ground it was like this all black I just
drop his pants no no it was he was
telling me about not to [ __ ] it was such
a moment it was so iconic
that's great see I miss all that see
people that don't like that they've
never enjoyed a talent show yes like a
college talent show or a local talent
show is the best thing on earth because
half of the performers or that one's
saying hey watch you don't want nobody
wants to actually watch frisbee tricks
people want to watch a guy who thinks
physic frisbee tricks is awesome yes
get doing frisbee yeah and all because
you could see you just see the passion
that they're trying to bring it back
like they're gonna be the person who
brings back frisbee tricks hula hooping
or whatever and make it mainstream
because they're gonna like do with the
hip hop tricks has never gone to the
next level and that's what I'm trying to
do it yeah like I'm out dude I'm out
I've way out
it's like y'all juggling school but like
I'm gonna do it to Jay Z right exam yeah
they're like oh I got a Kinect yes being
a frisbee I thought it was so funny that
I was looking at some these different
schools and one of the curriculums that
they have is Ultimate Frisbee I'm like
what do you mean schools what kind of
school in like the schools in your area
I was looking at the curriculums that
they have Wow like I like intermediate
elements oh yeah no it was in high
school Ultimo's being high school like
that's pretty cool it's a client liked
it yeah oh my god like there was fencing
Ultimate Frisbee there was very I wanted
to fence ever since I saw The Parent
Trap like extra and fun that movie know
there's so exaggerated I like the math
yeah and the suit is just sexy until you
have fencing class of the air in LA
that's so kind looked up I think this is
website that they show you open to
different classes mm-hm fencing you're
gonna do it what the hell were you
looking up for like I'm looking up
classes that I'm not gonna take like hey
look at this class what's this one
swimming no archery learning how to
catch and kill and prepare it to yes are
you talking about this I want to but I
found them I just never did that's
throwing OH
like you learn how to throw an accent at
a bull's-eye you know you want the axe
actually stick on the target and not
like bounce the handle off of it that's
what it teaches you but I
okay so there's allegedly a bar yeah
okay I'm not going there I didn't think
you were actually throwing an axe
wait you're drinking that's going so now
I'm like it's like hey two-for-one get
whiskey and an axe it's like it's called
lax weird and you can drink
whoa I think they're trying to get the
liquor license but other places
around the country have it yeah so it's
like going bowling but then you just
don't act I hope that they give it one
protective eyewear or something shitty
like that it's like that wouldn't help I
think last week goes tonight is about
the girl who like through the acts so it
like bounced off of the board and then
it hit the rubber matting on the floor I
mean not the floor the board and then it
hit the floor and then it bounced back
out her but she had enough reflex to
like see it coming his sheep DUP and it
missed her head and it killed the person
behind her yes but now imagine if she
was drinking she'd just see that [ __ ]
and [ __ ] hit her in the forehead I
think I mean makes you start serving
alcohol shooting ranges know what
they're doing I can't do Ally gun club
because that one is it's indoors and
then you're just like in a little
cubicle and then next to you are
strangers with guns and I can't do it
but that's every range I've been to I
like outdoor range just cuz you have
your own like cuz I'll just see them
like doing the most careless [ __ ] and
they're like and I'm like holy [ __ ]
you're gonna [ __ ] kill me isn't the
axe and like ax bar concept the same as
having darts at a bar to just throwing
like these sharp needles right and
people are drinking and getting really
drunk smaller dial it's not a one shot
kid oh yeah room for error
[Laughter]
it was so drunk I think it's just exist
see even better that actually helped him
with getting hit by a dart that's nice
that's why they're serving [ __ ] yeah
that's nice but if he was sober nobody's
seen it coming and he would add stuff I
like all have you by the bang
served it I mean all that [ __ ] that
happened Tim was karma like it needed to
hit his head he learned his lesson I
hope what do you make of the current
state of YouTube you're an old-timer on
YouTube what do you make of Akron City
like there's just so much happening
I read somebody just got arrested for
what child pornography yes like was like
luring girls to send up nudes or
something yeah that guy was I think he
got caught years ago but now he's
finally getting prison time for it or
something he's got one of those faces to
I'm like I get one yeah yeah I mean I
don't think it's there's a lot going on
but then like I've talked about him day
like remember like Sam pepper look
there's always people doing stuff I just
feel like the internet now is so it's
just big a stream that everything seems
like a bigger deal because it is because
there's more people online yeah Steve
asking the hard questions are you
originally from LA - I'm from Missouri I
was born in Arkansas and I knew from
Missouri yeah the venire since 2011 so
what'd you think of the Rams leaving
unbelievable oh my god that was just a
mess that was an emotional wreck like
last season with such you didn't know if
you wanted to root for them I want to
Kansas City to make it just because
that's still home I'm a lot of our home
world set it's just drama I don't really
care because I don't like football that
much it was like a thing where I just
rooted for the Rams because I'm from
there listen that's more than most
youtubers I'm gonna believe me yeah
we're watching that last night but a lot
of tubers they there they don't even
[ __ ] watch the game I'm in a fantasy
football league the tubers who were just
like the only people on the entire
medium who like liked football I like I
like the Mighty Ducks football team
nice great last year so when they're in
the Super Bowl did you root for them
well your rants um kind of I know a
couple people on the cheerleading team
so yeah yeah I was just want to see real
loss whose life I'm still thought to you
what are the rounds go here they left do
you have eyes [ __ ] billboards
everywhere
came back came back oh I saw that the
Raiders are going to Vegas that's my I
saw he was you know the fresh LA merch
people walk around with with Rams
jerseys like they always had them on
even though they're brand new with
[ __ ] tags on them and [ __ ] just like
when the Seahawks won who's your team
the Colts Colts here how come here go
with the Colts I was born in any apples
so I've always followed them oh pretty
much yeah because I was in a big family
like like I have a older sister and two
little brothers and we're all from
different states because we were all
born a couple years apart so they're all
fans of different teams yes so job to
have our most identity that we were
different from each other like it's like
oh I'm a cult fan cuz I'm from Indiana
so [ __ ] you you can't write the Colts
you know I mean and like my other
brother likes the Redskins and that's
been a nightmare for him and my sister
likes the Cowboys and she was born
probably ten years too late for that
[ __ ] like sorry Cowboys fans but my god
sounds like your house was a mess it's a
man nightmare what about your dad what
he doesn't like football he's kind of a
nerd but he but he would watch it with
us
just because he wants the Super Bowl
basketball oh my gosh
well my nephew loves uh LeBron so he
loved the Lakers that my parents loved
Golden State um personally I grew up
liking the Lakers even before with here
yeah just cuz Shaq was on a team and
like using like all the kids stuff um in
st. Louis didn't have a basketball team
so the Lakers have always been it for me
like genuinely not just because I moved
here yeah I like the Bulls just cuz MJ
of course those totally just sucked into
all that [ __ ] that's like a distant
memory for me he like I remember it but
I don't feel like I experienced it like
I was just - he was such a part of the
culture for me that I remember playing
NBA Jam and being like where the [ __ ] is
Michael Jordan why isn't he in this game
cuz he wasn't in the game could they not
afford him I think so yeah cuz he had
his own endorsement deals and [ __ ] but
yeah I remember he was just such a part
of the culture I wasn't even like into
basketball he just sucked everybody I
remember all my friends watching Space
Jam yeah but since I was not to watch
movies dance on my head since you
brought up Michael
yeah haha alright remember I believe I
can fly was on this piece know you think
are what do you think of what's going on
with our an innocent man accused of
something he didn't do right I just
deleted that thing from my DVR because
it was disgusting really I couldn't even
finish it yeah laughing at him since the
dawn of time like a bad American Idol
audition yeah isn't it like I think in
high school I realize how crazy he was
and it was difficult to take his music
seriously like his musically of course
he's he's a genius he's good dropping
applause exactly but when you start
understanding who he is as a human being
you go this guy's not yeah my first like
I remember space him I believe I can fly
but I one of my earliest memories of him
is hearing that he peed on someone I
heard it too but I forgave him in the
moment yeah as a kid when I heard that I
thought was the funniest thing ever and
I just thought like he made it cuz I
always thought it's a you you you're
golden entertainments to get yourself to
level we can pee on people and although
he made it like who else who else is in
teen that's why I didn't think the
peeing was a sexual thing I thought pink
as I was so young when it happened I
think the peeing was like oh he's just a
dick like he has so much money now he
treats people like [ __ ] that young cuz I
think I was like in ninth grade you like
the Beatles peed on people I bet you
everyone like the eagle fly peed on
people we know me but not on a fourteen
year old child when your third of
something that part I didn't I forgot
how old she was
yeah I didn't comprehend go was the same
age as the girl at the same time so we
didn't mind probably know didn't know a
bit of pee what the hell yeah it was
like I was like if I was 15 and she was
15 I put myself in her shoes and I'm
like Oh Britney Spears PETA I'm gonna be
awesome yeah you put your you put your
I'm 15 now hat on yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]